breaking news and the transport
secretary has just announced changes to
england's international travel rules
from monday the 4th of october the
current traffic light system will be
replaced by a two-tier system that is a
red list of countries and the rest of
the world
fully vaccinated travellers from non-red
list countries will be able to replace
day two pcr tests with cheaper lateral
flow tests from the end of october
they will also no longer need to take
pre-departure tests
from next wednesday the 22nd of
september eight more destinations will
be removed from the red list and they
include turkey and pakistan our
correspondent nick martin joins me now
from westminster hello to you nick so
these long-awaited changes announced by
grant schatz what do they mean
it means that travel is going to be a
lot easier and if you're watching this
and you're planning a holiday and you've
been trying to negotiate the system
throughout the summer with tests and
when to do tests and how much tests cost
the good news is this is a far simpler
and straightforward system it's fair to
say that the government have relaxed an
awful lot of rules and it all hinges on
whether you're vaccinated or whether
you're unvaccinated the headlines really
are that this is a simplified system out
goes the traffic lights the red amber
and green we've now got red
a red list countries and the rest of uh
the world the testing requirements have
been significantly reduced as you said
from monday october the 4th 4 am
fully vaccinated people returning from
non-red list countries that'll now be
replaced with a day two two days after
you arrive and eight days a lateral flow
test much much cheaper much quicker than
the pcr tests and that's really quite
significant that has been a lot of the
additional costs that people have had to
bear this summer as they wanted to go on
holiday the cost of those pre-departure
tests and those tests at day two and day
eight they've been pretty expensive the
government says now that if you're
vaccinated fully vaccinated under a
recognized vaccination scheme those
tests can now be replaced by a lateral
flow test and that says the government
that once they want that to be
introduced by the end of october that's
in time for people returning back from
the half term so that's really quite
significant um as i say testing
requirements have been reduced the
government wants to reduce it wants to
introduce this by the end of october if
you have a positive test you still the
government says has to i have to isolate
but there's another critical change here
because previously you've had to pay for
pcr tests these for the vaccinated will
now be available on the nhs and that's a
really quite significant step forward so
if you're coming back from holiday from
a non-red less country you don't have to
pay for an expensive test you can take
one of those lateral flow tests now the
redless countries there's been a long
list of countries taken off the red list
turkey pakistan the maldives egypt oman
bangladesh and kenya that's effective
from september the 22nd and there's a
little warning for those who are perhaps
still not vaccinated the unvaccinated
will still have to take day two and day
eight pcr tests and it's not clear and
it might we will try and clear this up
it might be getting cleared up soon
whether those pcr tests will still have
to be privately funded therefore still
quite expensive or whether they will be
available on the nhs as they have become
now available for those who are
vaccinated returning from non-red list
countries this is effectively a
massively reduced less complicated
system and underlying all of this is a
drive to get us moving again not just
families but businesses and that global
interconnections travel for the last 18
months has been and sometimes now on
impossible the last few months very
expensive and quite complicated although
people have been traveling this is
designed quite clearly to get people on
the move again it is an economic boost
to the travel industry and it'll mean
that people are able to to book their
holidays and not have to worry about
whether that country might be moved from
red to amber people still returning back
from a redless country will still have
to do that managed isolation in
hospitals and things like that but um
for the vast majority of people coming
back from non-red list countries it will
be far far simpler there
nick we have uh heard from the transport
secretary client chaps in the last few
moments let's have a listen to what he
has to say
we wanted to bring it a new simpler
easier to navigate and cheaper system as
well and so we brought this in uh to the
new year the uh at the very least and
the purpose is to make it easier for
people to travel without the bureaucracy
without so many tests uh and with a
greater level of certainty now that
we've got so many people vaccinated
nick just looking through the
government's notes on this what is clear
is if you're fully vaccinated the aim is
to make it much easier if you're
unvaccinated it's actually going to get
tougher
if you were coming back from what would
have been a green list country for
example because now the baseline travel
requirement for somebody who is
unvaccinated is home quarantine for 10
days
yeah that's right home quarantine for 10
days test release on day five
day two and day eight tests it's very
obvious what the government are doing
here this is that this is a little nudge
to those who are not vaccinated to say
that you are not going to be able to
travel in the same way that people who
have chosen to be vaccinated are and
we've seen this kind of nudge throughout
the pandemic just especially since the
vaccinations have been available and
this is very clearly saying if you're
not vaccinated then travel will still be
quite significantly more complicated and
in many cases uh more expensive in fact
in probably all cases expensive and your
time that your restrictions will be
still placed upon you and that could
help just to dislodge some of the
doubters uh who are still remaining here
who do not want to get the vaccination
who might want to you might see their
friends who double jabbed going away on
holiday skipping away knowing that they
just have to take lateral flow tests
when they get back
those people who aren't vaccinated will
have a far more uh difficult uh journey
they're also trying to extend some of
the um
reduce some of the restrictions for
people who are coming in from countries
where we are we now recognize those
vaccinations so the government are
saying they're going to recognize um
people coming in from
a selected amount of countries who've
had modern uh
the johnson and johnson the astrazeneca
and those people who may have had a a
mix of the two vaccines they'll still be
able to uh come in under those new
relaxed rules and so a significant
stripping away of of a lot of the a lot
of the restrictions that travelers have
been working under operating under for
so long and it'll certainly be very
welcome by the travel companies in fact
you would imagine right now people
googling flights trying to get back away
on holiday knowing that just a little
bit easier just a little bit more peace
of mind that they're not going to be hit
with a big uh hotel bill for example if
the country suddenly moves from an amber
to to a red and so travel companies i
would expect will be quite happy with
this this is what they've been asking
for of the government for some time and
it will certainly reduce a lot of the
costs that have been involved in uh
going on holiday lateral flow tests
which are the instant tests involving a
swab and dropping them on a little um
reader they only take about half an hour
they're very very cheap the pcr tests
have sometimes been 80 120 pounds and so
these have all been removed now making
travel a lot easier so a significant
announcement by grant shaps and the
government effectively
getting people moving again and moving
is good for people's health it's good
for their families holidays are clearly
good for people but it's also going to
be good for global travel and the
economy in general